all right everyone thanks for coming so
today we're going to be talking about
building fast and beautiful apps exam
reforms which might surprises so I'm
Michael woodlanders MMB P community
bloggers do lots of open source stuff
and basically been doing downward for
five years and have a team and we love
them run and examine what we do and so
just the agenda for today we're going to
go through some misconceptions and Kuras
those are some of the styling features
in xamarin forms go through some
performance tips understanding the
layout system and then go through the
pages and layouts and controls that are
available in several forms and some of
the animations and ask how many people
have used several forms before how many
people are using it a lot
full-time do people call slips and
people that have been doing general
forms which is good sometimes like
answer can be pretty low so if seven
forms flow I guess it's the big question
a lot of people say that it is you read
a lot about the Internet so why do
people say it's low that's what they
heard on reddit I don't think you should
believe everything you hear
on reddit some people some of the
comments have some validity but many of
the comments sound like somebody's used
it for about two hours and gave up after
that so past experiences so if you try
add some reforms when I was 1.0 or 18
months ago it was a lot that the
experiences that you can do now in the
apps that you can develop now are a lot
different then how was when I was first
released because I was pretty slow when
I was first released but they've built a
lot of features that actually enable you
to build better performing done reforms
apps so there's certain parts of them
reforms that are slow and the certain
parts of the fast I guess that's what
we'll be going over today so just sort
of understand there's areas that you can
go towards that actually going to give
you a better perform
at inserm response is easy so easy can
be deceiving so it's easy to go in and
download xamarin and start using as ever
forms application and it feels like a
WPF application so you're going to do
lots of nesting and add lots of UI
elements but you still want to phone
with limited resources and if you are in
WPF I've done WPF in the past and if you
did WPF poorly and the views weren't
done very well the application wasn't
built very nice it was quite forgiving
it wasn't like that location was going
to fall over but if you do that in
Xiamen forms then you can get yourself
into trouble it's just not as forgiving
and so with form you have to build pages
with performance in mind if you want
something that's going to run really
fast so their important is fast but it's
not forgiving so I just wanted to give
you like so this is taken from the zone
website it's actually should I actually
be using some reforms or should I be
using xamarin traditional German iOS and
Zimmer and Android so if you actually
have a look at this you can see it's
saying for them reform should be for
data entry applications prototypes when
you're not using a lot of platforms of
CV KPIs or you don't have a highly
polished design so I'm just going to
give you a demo of some apps
but actually you'll see a bit of a delay
on the screen up there but when it's on
the phone it's a lot faster
so this one might take a little bit of
the internet back
so I'm just going to go through add my
address here select my address it's
going to go back to the server
hopefully the internet doesn't take too
long so you can see there we've got some
light nice spinning animations some
animations and we have to find the
address to go through creating your
account
use touch ID so some native API there go
through have some animations that we go
through dating
that same animation
so I'm just going to find some practices
so all this stuff that I'm showing is
built with some reforms so as I'm going
through what you actually see so given
that so the apps that I just demoed
there do you think they will built with
the Zemin iOS or some reforms
well I will built built we've done some
reforms so you can actually do what it
says you can't do here and the great
thing about some reforms is you can
actually do a highly polished design and
it's still going to be cross-platform
you're still going to have a demo page
to edit and we're still going to have
the cross-platform mvvm and one code
base to actually manage most of those
applications you saw there were about 90
percent code sharing between iOS and
Android
so what's last two pages with less
elements so the more elements that you
add to some reform space the more that
can slow down post layout animations and
translations we'll get into this a
little bit later so if you're leveraging
the performance features that are
available in some reforms and if you're
following the recommendations of them
xamarin provide you can actually build a
fast application and there's some
third-party tools like FF image loader
that you can use so in summer and forms
and especially on Android this is like
more of an Android issue every time you
load up an image it's converted into a
bitmap so you can easily get them out of
memory exceptions FF mutilator will
actually case images and it will reduce
the size before it gets translated into
a bitmap in the Android system so if
you're if you've got a lot of images and
you're doing different forms on Android
you definitely want to be using FF image
loader so so what slow overloaded pages
with deep nesting so the one thing about
some forms this is probably saleable if
you actually really wanted to do it you
still going to look at
- 30 seconds for the app startup versus
less than a second from the file new
German iOS or the renowned Pedroia
application so you probably could work
around it by actually having some native
areas that load up first and for them
reforms loads up there causing too many
layout sizes which we'll go into a
little bit later dynamically building UI
elements which is something that you
like to do but if you can avoid it can
actually speed up your vacation and if
you're actually doing a lot of sort of
dynamic building of UI elements that can
be a problem and you don't actually need
to do it there's actually ways that you
can build your UI without having to do
dynamically building your UI elements
and ignoring the performance
recommendations so how do I build fast
and beautiful apps as Emma reforms so
beautiful it's not always about the
platform so when we build apps we
actually start with UX design so
actually if you try and take some big
ERP application and just put it onto a
mobile device you can have a lot of
problems you just going to be you're not
really going to have a refined UI we
only got the elements that you need so
normally we do UX design and we actually
iterate it will iterate on it multiple
times so we can actually refine the
design to only contain two things that
needs to contain and then once we do all
iterations on the UX design and then
we'll move to the visual design so an
app that starts with good visual design
and in like a good visual experience on
the device so if you don't have the
visual design you don't actually know
what's going to come out of that
development but any app that we've
worked on where we actually folks have
visual designs that have done really
nice at that get ends up nice so there's
definitely a distinction there and fast
is not always about the platform so in
your application there's lots of
different things you can do if occation
so you can do dedication view caching
image casing and sort of background
downloading also the sequence so I've
seen some applications where people will
actually go and they'll start
downloading things and then I wait for
that download to finish and then they'll
create all their views and then they'll
try and display their views where really
you could actually create or you can
start the download in the background and
then you can push your views whites
downloading in the background show you
view and then when the download is
completed you can actually populate the
missing parts of the view which is as
much you've already loaded the view so
you're just updating various areas of
the application so I'll just talk about
some styling features as ever informs so
here we've got the app resources so in
the application resources you can have a
like a dictionary which contains
different styles so you can see here
I've got a heading style the target type
is a label and all that sizes on there
I've got a font family different text
colors so this is when you have a design
which is kind of static it's not going
to change you don't want to actually
have like a light theme or a dusting you
can just put them directly into
application otherwise if you have you
want to change the styles on the fly you
can actually dynamically modify the
application resources so the other thing
you can do is custom fonts so all you
need to do is include the to try point
in each project and set the font family
on the label you will need a custom
renderer for Pickers but it can be done
and a lot of the time if you get an app
is in visual design it's going to have a
custom font and it does make a
difference on how your app looks in the
end so some reforms that a lot of it is
actually built on custom renderers so
anytime you have an entry or a ListView
pretty much every control that you use
in Xiamen forms is going to have a
custom renderer so in this case in this
diagram you can see we've got this entry
here for iOS I've got an entry renderer
in this case we've done a custom
renderer of the base renderer is an
entry renderer which so basically what
happens in them informed is you have an
entry which is a model that you're
saying this is how I want it to actually
look and then for each platform you have
the custom implementation which will
actually show the custom the custom UI
elements and in this case my entry is
actually inherited from the entry
renderer and you're actually making the
changes yourself so this is an example
of a custom renderer so you can see here
I'm inheriting the label renderer to
create my own font label renderer so
exporting a label with the font label
renderer and then we can also do that
so in that case previously I was
inheriting the built-in label renderer
which is already there but you can also
do it where you actually implement the
base renderer and you have full control
over the the native API so basically
where we've got this Google map control
is the one that we saw on the app before
and it's pretty much just a native
window to native so yeah full control
over there you've got full access to the
native API and you can basically put
whatever native third party element or
anything that you like in there
yeah so that's custom renderers so
effects effects like custom renderers
but they are attached so rather than
using inheritance because with the
custom renderer that you always have a
control and then you have a custom
renderer and that's a one-to-one mapping
where as I can control in some forms can
have multiple effects applied to it so
it's more like a feature so it's just a
lighter version of a custom renderer so
you can change the properties on the
native control so you can actually have
an effect that only comes into effect on
iOS and Android it's not used so you use
that when there's certain things you
want to do on certain platforms so yeah
so it's added as a feature to the
control so you can see some examples
that you've got like an underline effect
a border effect or a shadow effect
whatever you like and this is like a
similar diagram where you're adding the
add effect to the slider so you've got
the on attach methods detach methods
I'll take you through some code samples
in a second so you can see here this is
the iOS border effect on the attach
method it's changing the border color to
a purple and the border widths and then
when this detaching it's changing the
the border width back and then on this
entry element it's actually adding the
border effect so one thing that was
recently released which is pretty cool
is native embedding so what actually
allows you to do is take a control
hierarchy which is German forms and it's
cross-platform and directly embed native
elements into it so if we're actually so
this here is the split view controller
which is iOS only and you can either do
that in code or you can do that in zamel
so we can see this picture here you have
got the mave embedding the android
widget so text view is basically an
entry element for Android whereas if we
look down further
we've with iOS we've got a UI label so
anything that starts with UI means you
like it so we've got like a UI label
there a UI text view which is like at an
entry field the good thing about native
embedding is it actually supports the
the data binding so you can basically
take a native element from iOS and you
can actually data bind directly to it
one of the other things you can do is
handle different screen sizes so if you
actually just have a look over here I'm
over style for the heart request and
depending on if it's a phone or a tablet
I'm setting a different value and you
can also do that in code
so you know if it's a tablet or a fad
the phone sometimes you want some more
granular abilities to change size so
generally these days it's quite easy
thing to do
is on one of the first pages they just
hook up to the slides changed and then
in the app I've set the width and height
and then I can come and a lot of use
that width and height later in the
application if I want to change the size
of things let's have a look at an
application so let us take you through
some of the features so if you're not
seeing like what what does Emran
applicator solution looks like and in
this case this is just an Android and
iOS project so I've got my portable
class library here you can actually do
dotnet standard but we're just been
doing PC ELLs at the moment we'll
probably look at doesn''t standard when
it is been out for a while because with
xamarin when PC elseís came out we'd
have lots of trouble with that so a
little bit scared to go to dotnet
standard and what that actually means so
we're sticking with the PCL so now so
this is the portable library so this
actually has our different demo controls
our C sharp which is shared then you've
got our iOS project which references the
portable class library and so one thing
to note that when you're going to the
iOS projects you'll see things that
exactly these exactly the same as what
an iOS developer will see so if you are
iOS developer you know what an
application delegate is you know this
finished launching event whereas if you
go into the Android project you have an
activity so this is what an Android
developer normally does but the goal of
what we're doing with other forms is
actually to keep a lot of the code out
of these two projects and keep it in a
shared library
so if we actually have a look at some of
the features that I talked about so you
can see here in my application I've got
my resources in here so got my heading
style put up some font sizes so just
taking this gray button style for
example if I go on following that so on
this post view I've just got this style
applied via a static resource I mean
it's quite good to have them especially
if you have a large application that's
got lots of common styles and it's good
to set them off at the start and then
you can use them across the board so one
of the other things that I discussed is
our custom renders so in this
application that I've been playing
around with I needed to have a ListView
where I could actually know where it had
been scroll to so the normal this UN's
mm forms
doesn't actually have this event on it
so I had to actually inherit from the
zem reform unless you and I've added
like a little stroll action there and
then down in my iOS project as you can
see I'm going to my OS under renderers
I've got my advanced listeria renderer
so up here I declare that I've got my
advanced ListView renderer my advanced
su has a render of advanced elusive
renderer so you can see it's a
one-to-one mapping but I didn't really
have a choice because I needed to get
inside the control and I'm inheriting
from the built-in lassoo renderer I mean
the list you render that counters and
forms is quite complex so I wouldn't
want to go and create my own one almost
better to leverage what's actually there
and all I do is when there's a new
element I hook up to the scrolled event
and then I pass that through to the the
portable class library so Dameron forms
even though it's sort of it's cool
platform it really has all these
different extensibility points where if
you actually get into that trouble or
something
that needs to be native you can actually
jump out those and reforms and you can
go do things in natives either wire
effects or through custom renderers so
another example that we saw one time we
talked about was the effects so by
default and entry in some reforms on iOS
actually has a border so to remove that
I've just created a a no border entry
effect and then down here in my iOS
project you can see I've got my no
border which basically grabs the control
which is a text field sets the border
style and since the background color so
it actually makes the the background
removes the border that we didn't
actually want
so just going over some performance tips
obviously as I'm reforms performances is
a big deal and people do want actually
know about this so we'll just go just a
little bit into it so previously when in
the earlier versions of xamarin formed
the list view every time you created a
saw a new sell a new view was created
and then this whole new view was created
then the binding context was updated so
this especially before that has MOC I
was positive inflating all this zamel
every time you saw a a new cell so now
we have this in cordless you still
recycling so it basically takes the
views and allows you to recycle them so
rather than creating a new view every
time it'll take an old one that it's
actually already displayed and it will
just update the binding context so
there's just a certain amount of views I
mean if you actually test it out you can
notice there's only three or four views
depending on how many actually displayed
on the screen and it was actually
recycle them through iOS it's actually
sort of a technique that iOS and Android
use or mail lists as well so the
performance improvements are huge it's
disabled by default so you have to go in
and actually enable it so you can see
here the retainer element is actually
the default but recycle element is what
you want so I've actually done that on
this project so in my advanced list you
I've inherited woman and I've actually
changed location strategy to recycle
element
so the data template selector so it
allows the cell recycle obviously uses a
performance but sometimes you want to
have the cell recycling but you want to
have different types of views displayed
in your your list so the data template
selected will actually allow you to have
these four types of views and it gives
you the support for the solar recycling
so in this example you can see who's you
imagine the the chat window in in iOS
where you've got an incoming message or
exotic outgoing message so you can see
here when the template is selected if
the message is incoming it'll show the
incoming data template otherwise it'll
show the outgoing data template just to
give you an example of words used to
actually build an app
so this list here this is a like a list
to exam reforms list view and it's using
a data template selector so where you've
got the tip like the header up there
that's actually one data template type
the next one down is a different one
further down where you're actually
listing out the stocks here that's a
data template type and it's just
replacing the data so you're getting
that solar cycling and then also when
you're actually going down here it's
actually using this all recycling and
anytime I mean we'll go into the slide a
bit
anytime you have a really big view to
show enzyme reforms you want to be
leveraging our list view because the
list you actually doesn't do
calculations for things that are off the
screen whereas if you're using a grid
with like a scroll view it actually
calculates everything so you know if you
have a huge page which you're not using
LSU and it's over sort of like six
screens with a scroll view you're going
to feel the performance in that so Zemel
then we'll see so previously in the
early versions of several
zamel was caused and inflated at runtime
but now you can actually have them OC
enabled which means that it's positon
turned into oil at compile time and so
it's faster there's a small app size so
they don't actually include all the demo
files in the project and you see them
all errors at the all time so this means
some data on demo c vs the inflated
versus compiled the blue one is the
inflated performance how long it takes
where the red one is to compile so
overall it's about five times faster it
does increase real time a little bit
about sixteen seconds but it's worth it
for the performance and that our data
syncs to matthew problems as empresa so
one of the biggest things that you can
do resume inform performance is like
simplify the layout and reduce the
nesting ones best way to do that is
you know your controls use the right
control for the right job so for example
this person has basically three labels
of one two three and they're trying to
add padding and spacing and they're
doing it using a Content view which is
actually sort of adding lots of extra
native views that no need to be there or
is if they'd known that the stack loads
have had padding and spacing then they
could have just done that I mean it's
just good even if you don't know the
full API set of them reforms just when
you're building if you just think about
how am i how can i what's going to be
available for me to be able to reduce
the size of this and the nesting of the
sizes it's you so know you control to
avoid relative layout so the xamarin
recommend whilst they recommend that you
don't use it obviously it was one thing
that they brought out whenever balls
initially came out but they recommend
just to stay away from it because the
performance hit on it it's so big so the
grid helps you reduce nesting and layout
cycles don't put a ListView inside a
scrollview use the header and footer so
what people will do is they'll get a
they get a ListView and then they'll put
a grid with a header and then they'll
put what a scrollview and then put a
grid with a header and then I'll put the
list you inside that but what actually
happens is if one of the bits of text
changed it inside the degree it does a
full layout cycle and the ListView does
a complete layout again whereas if it's
just a ListView and then it doesn't have
the layout slice and problem issue
don't use message stack layouts and you
can use a grid so it's a clout is great
when you've just got a stacks and things
on top of each other or stack them
horizontally but if you start nesting
them so you do a horizontal and then a
vertical one you're better off just
using a grid so anytime you just want to
stack some things on top of each other
use a stuff layer otherwise the mix is
multiple things either within areas of
an application you use a grid and don't
use a grid when you can use the stack
layer as I said before stack layouts
good when you've just got things that
want to go on top of each other and
don't need a stack layered as a list you
so if you go to like a list of items use
a ListView
so on a grid there's three options for a
width or height so you can use star or
you can use a static value or you can
use an order
stay away sand water and stick to is a
star or the static width
I'm prefer using the allowed options
still these are the default so there's
other options that you can just start
and end but muting it feels better and
you'll see why as it moves along so what
I'm talking about now is the zone
performs layout system and this is
actually internal to them reforms you
don't actually need to know this to
build them in forms but it's just good
to know this type of stuff if you're
building with urban forms just to
understand the Lao system understand how
things are working or why something
might be running slow so the lessons
into cycles the invalidation cycle so
you have a label the text changes the
slides becomes invalidated it needs to
bubble that up to its parents under the
layout cycle inertia does the layout so
the invalidation cycle so every the
visual element which is the base class
of layouts views and pages or have a
measure invalidated event handler so
this is from the source code of
Zimmerman forms so you don't actually
you will know about CVS when you're
building this is just for Theoretical
purposes so you've got the measures
invalidated then every time a child is
added to a layout or a page that page
was run to that child measure
invalidated event and then actually when
just say like a label the text changes
in it and the uncharred measure
invalidated is called and then it goes
through some conditional logic and then
it actually calls the event on itself
which will in actually call the method
on the parent so current looks like this
so you're a page and then it's hooked up
to the stacks way up as event and then
the stack allowed has three children
which it's been hooked up to all three
of the events on the children so just
say the label the text changes in the
label the sides become
so the measure becomes invalidated that
will pop up to the stack layer then the
stack layout will say yet why need it on
my parent and it will go up again so
there is some conditional logic which
will actually that happens in between
that so we can look at the the layout
cycle which is the other cycle so once
we've had the invalidation cycle then
we've decided to lay things out what
happened is it before it lays anything
you know that measures and it can
measure multiple times so I plan out the
grid and stuff allow it to have multiple
rounds of measuring and then it will do
the layup so if we can put it all
together first for doing the
invalidation and then we're doing the
layout the layout so why do we actually
care about what this does because we can
hack it so you can see there's so many
things that are going on there which
doesn't look very nice you obviously
don't want things like that to be
happening in applications so when a
label changes you can actually set it up
so just this happens and doesn't do a
full way out of the whole system I'm
just going to give you a demo of that if
I can you switch
so just to show you the two of us that
we're going to be looking at in this
demo first we've got a stack layup and
it's got ten labels in it and the bottom
label down here has a counter label it's
got a name then in the code-behind of
this every half a second we actually
change the counter label text so it's
actually resizing and changing the text
there and then if we actually have a
look at the grid we have the same setup
without counter label and then in the
code behind updating I count up to 20 so
let's just have a look at what happens
there so what I've actually done is this
some code base so now if you can see
down there that is linked up to the Sam
reforms code base so we are put in
performance metrics to actually track
what's actually happening internally the
inside zone reforms so if we have a look
at application output there riff will be
able to see that and see that so if I
open up the stack layout you can see
here my counter is changing but what you
can also see down the bottom here the
one that we're primarily concerned with
is the layout child into the bounding
region or where you can see is as that's
gone through
layout child it's a bounding region has
happened 263 times so if I just go back
do that again you actually see it going
up
it's not cool so let's have a look at
the grid so you can see our cameras
going up you know good let me have a
look down here at our core count that's
just sitting there at 13 so what's
actually happening there so the grid
because in the grid I'm actually using a
estar width
so by by star which means that it just
takes up the remaining space and the
grid actually knows if it's a star if
it's a static width um on all areas
which the child what all areas of the
grid of the child is covering it knows
that the child is fully constrained so
it doesn't need to recalculate
everything so it doesn't do those
recalculations but if I change this to
auto a perilous what happens
so I've got my grid later layout and
I've got my kami going up there but
we've gone back to the call count of the
layout going up again so what actually
happens is as soon as you change like a
row to an auto height which like a view
is in it'll actually become not fully
can't be fully constrained so the grid
actually needs to do recalculation of
everything so that's why people say
avoid the order so Oh No maybe you have
some dynamic content in my Association
so what I'm going to do is rather than
have just a label we're going to have a
box um that's going to change the web
server just to move some things around
so on that time I'm just changing the
width request on the box but to change
this back
so you can see my application output
it's not going up but what's also not
happening is the width of the blue box
view is not actually changing so in
order to get that to work I need to
change the horizontal options so by
default the horizontal options are set
to fill so it's like filling out the
whole of the valuable space in that grid
view but as soon as you actually change
it to use one of the different corazon
two options which are still so now
that's working what if we have a look at
our application output the amount of
layouts that is actually doing is going
up again so what we can actually do is
if we take that box you import it inside
content
so it's still moving
I mean will changing width but if we
actually look at the call count it's not
going up so what's actually happening
there is when you change it to a
horizontal options and it's the first
child over grid then it cannot be fully
constrained view but what actually
happens in this case is the content view
is a fully constrained view so the grid
knows that it doesn't have to relay out
anything for the content view so the
event will go from the box view after
the content view and then are all
stopped off of the content view so now
those performance things that we get
told about the reforms kind of make
sense so reduce nesting obviously you
saw how much stuff goes online is like a
layout cycle don't change the defaults
of the horizontal options of vertical
options because fill is good use grid
but avoid the auto and don't use a stack
ladders list view obviously you can see
with a stack layout when anything image
file changes it's going to do a full
layout on basically the whole page so
I'm just conference about some reforms
pages layers and patrols so this is kind
of going back to basics of some reforms
so every time you have a zimmern forms
application whenever you want to show
something that's always going to you
always gonna have a content view so
anytime you have any bit of any view on
the screen it's probably going to be
inside the content view and then
obviously here you got a master detail
so that's your flyout menu on some left
inside and then also the the tab page
here so that's your tabs at the bottom
anytime you want to do navigation enzyme
reforms you're going to need a
navigation page because you won't be
able to navigate without it so generally
the way that an application would look
is you've got like a navigation page and
then a content page or a tabbed page and
then a Content page but you can actually
miss the content master detail
the master detail navigation on tab page
so it depends depending on how you
structure the page that can change how
it actually behaves so if you have a
tabbed page with the child one of the
tabs our child as a navigation page and
then the content page when you navigate
on that child you're still going to see
the tab bar because the tab bar is at
the root of the system whereas if you
have a navigation page and then a tab
page when you actually navigate you're
actually going to or the tab page is
actually going to disappear just because
the navigation page is part of the is
the root in this case and you can
obviously other thing that you can do is
you have a master detail with a Tad's
page as well and don't use a carousel
page
samer and don't recommend it they
recommend avoiding the carousel page
there's a carousel view that's meant to
replace it which last I checked it
wasn't my shoe released but I think is
pretty stable so some of the layout so
this I've mentioned the stock way up the
stuff way out is great if you just wanna
stack things on top of each other or
horizontally the absolute layouts pretty
good you can do layering with it it
doesn't look that good if you're doing
if you're using demo as I was saying
before don't use a relative layout the
grid is an amazing control it really
allows you to reduce your nesting well
one other thing that you can do what
others a few lots of things you can do
with the grid but you can actually do
layering so if you actually want to
layer images on top of each other or
have a bit of content that's overlaid on
top of each other then you can do that
easily with a grid content view that's
just a view if you want to sort of as an
extra padding or something like that
scroll view so a scroll view is so
generally like pages that come in two
things that you get a list page with a
list of items and then you get like a
details page when is a list of items
using less views that already has a
scroll view but when you're using a
detail page you normally want to put it
in the scroll view
to say somebody has a really tiny device
and you still want to support them using
the application then you can have a
scroll view and I can do some scrolling
up and down a frame is like a content
view but it adds some nice rounding to
the view so stuck layout grids good in
the scroll view stay away from the
relatives so the grid it's actually the
grids quite easy to use this and it
works well with the rizal as well and
once you sort of get your head around
using the grid you can do almost
anything
Versalles em all and you can be used to
create really complex user interfaces
with it and it's easy to reduce the
nesting of notifications and as you saw
before it's easy to reduce the layout
cycles one thing that you can do with
the grooves when you're using a style
which fills out the rest of what's left
in an application you can actually put
numbers next to the staff so you can
have like a two star and 1/8 star and
that will give you a 20% and 80% so you
can actually use it to do sort of
percentage widths which works well when
you want to lay out things on different
screen sizes what's the time
do a little bit down
I'm just going to start building a grid
out here what's pretty cool these days
is have got ads Amal previewer so
previously you just when you opened it
the view I used to come up but now you
have to right-click and open it up so if
I start going to iOS there
I did some columns
what I'm actually going to do is just do
the to do it 20% slide bar we can't
actually see anything yet because they
don't have any content but if I put in a
box you the background color you can see
that's there let's actually add it
I'm going to change that along to one so
I can see you see there how you can use
the grid and you can try to get these
layouts which work on different nom
sizes so if I change that to a tablet
it's still going to have the 80% and the
20% one of the things you can actually
do layering as well so if I change this
had some rows
then if I make this red so you can
actually do views over mods for fans so
just change up to three
cool so you can see that that arm blue
is overlaid on top of the red someone
actually jump back to the presentation
so already mentioned the ListView but
it's really good like most of the
applications that we build that are
really nice leverage will issue a lot
and it's much faster now with the solar
cycling the data itself is selector and
alternative to grid so whenever there's
a dynamic number of rows you want to be
using the dalish you and you can add
avoid adding and removing views and
binding context changes so this is
actually going to cause what's the
layout cycles so you can actually
combine the controls so this view here
is quite a big unique one because most
of the stuff at the top is static as far
as how many elements are going to be
there but down the bottom we've actually
got a list there so you'd be tempted to
say put this in the scroll view I mean
in a stack layout and then dynamic we
have this thing down the bottom but if
you actually did that it would it
wouldn't even load it would take so long
for loads that it would be ridiculous so
the proper way to actually do this is to
have have internal if you have the top
part of the ListView header have the
bottom part as the difference a lot of
the ListView items obviously using your
own recycling and then down the bottom
here you can have 30 different comments
doesn't really matter and then actually
in the header I've actually used a grid
and pretty much I think mostly it's just
one view so you can see here where I've
actually got the pitch portrait there
and then I've actually got the play
button that's actually using the
layering features of the grid so one
other cool thing that's pretty cool in
some reforms is the animation framework
so the reforms actually before it was
them reform
they actually had a lot of animation was
actually part of the original code the
Cameron deforms was like an animation
framework so that's why some parts of
the reforms are slow but there's really
powerful animation framework and the
thing about and the animations are
they're post layout so they don't affect
the layout and they don't call layouts
so that's not they're fast and smooth so
it will not cause other elements to
layout if you move things around and
translations will not reset
during the layout cycles and it can be
kind combined to create complex
animations don't use layout too because
it's not post layout if you use layout
too when a page lays out again in a
reset the locations that you moved it to
so you got things like a scale to
translate rotate fades pretty much all
you want the only thing you can't do is
actually resize things but there is
actually ways to do that and we can
control the timing so if you want it to
go for one second or two seconds or half
second you've got the evening message in
there as well and you can combine it
with the will you can use them you
combine combine multiple animations
using async in the task parallel library
and you can have complex some
parent-child animations so you can do
lots of cool stuff so it's just a bit of
a dinner
so that this is just a simple animation
of coming here this is kind of a
combined animation where you're doing
multiple things you can also change
properties as well so I'll actually show
you something that I've been playing
around with but a you should be able to
go and get this code if you want and
play around with it all I'll give you
the the link so I've been trying to like
why I've only spent half a day doing it
reproduce the the facebook UI in Xiamen
forms or some of the cool things at
least so one of the cool things that I
noticed this is iOS the when you
actually scrolling up it actually hides
the little title bar so this is done in
general form for I'm actually using the
translation animation features of them
reforms to actually do that so other
thing is what I'm actually doing that
it's not relaying out anything it's
actually happening post layout so it's
actually just translating things around
the screen so if I go into my walls is
to you so what I've actually done in
this cases I've got a grid I've got two
rows one which is 80 which is the header
area another one which takes up the rest
what actually happens is the lists which
I'm displaying underneath it spans the
whole page because it has the row span
of two but I just translated down
initially so it actually just sits down
and then if we go up here I've got this
header which has a search bar and you
saw the images off and what happens as
it Scrolls up and down it just changes
the translation on them so that's how
you can actually get that nice scroll up
and down there now one other thing that
I do which
[Music]
so normally if you're going to do like a
menu and you want to do it really easily
you just use the master detail but some
of them in Facebook has this thing where
it comes out from the right and I wanted
to be able to do that as well so
basically using the same technique I've
actually I created friendly switches
just basic a list of the friends that
you see and I ship that below all the
other views on the page but I translated
across to the right so it's actually
actually just sitting off the screen
here and then when you open this I just
translate both of these list views
across that you can actually see them
come across so it's actually just moving
them across and then using the same
technique
one thing that um Facebook has is this
cool light button so that's sort of
coming in and that's using the same
technique where I've actually just put
this little view underneath and then as
I hit the like button I'm just changing
the translation of the wire and
animating it
if I have the friendlies open and I
scroll just scrolls
I mean Youth good so the question was
what happens if I have the friendlies
open and then I scroll at the moment
it'll just scroll you could actually set
it up so I mean we have worked on it
very long but you can set it up so it
actually closes you can kind of do
whatever you want in that case what you
would do is if you wanted it when
someone touches there if you wanted it
to close you would just put like a
transparent view over the top and then
when you get a touch on that and then
you just close it
yes that's it there's only questions
this should be microphone if anyone has
any questions how do you enable humbles
see is that like by default or yes okay
yeah so the question was there how do
you enable Zen we'll see it's actually
disabled by default they might change
that in the future but you can actually
enable it at assembly level
so we're just saying that we want to
compile the sample in this assembly so
you can actually enable it at the the
assembly let me just get rid of this
extra so you can enable it at the
assembler level but then if you want to
go to say a certain view then you can
actually disable it at the view level so
you can actually enable it for the most
part and then you can just keep it for
certain things
great any other questions so I'll be
I'll wait at the back for a little bit
after the presentation if you want to
come up and ask me any questions well
thank you very much
[Applause]